i look at people all the time and i
think all of you are living in this
place where it is but when but when but
when but when but when it's a nonsense
man this is it these are the good old
days you know we now look at photos of
our kids from two years ago oh they were
so small then two years ago we were
looking at photos of them two years
before going oh they're so small look
how beautiful they are you don't see it
when you're in it you can't wait until
you've got no stress or worry in your
life before you decide to be happy
because guess what you will always have
stress and worry and anxiety and
problems and issues to deal with so you
have to decide now that happiness is
something that you're going to have you
can't wait until you've been hugely
successful before you start focusing on
charity and giving and caring for other
people
jay humphrey welcome to the show
thanks very much for having me how are
you i'm good man i'm good all the way
from austin texas back to the uk
lovely i bet it's a little bit warmer
there than it is it's about three
degrees here in norwich today and we
i've been told it's minus five tonight
so i've been doing all the glamorous
stuff like getting the hose pipes in um
because they're going to freeze and
damage and covering the taps with
little thermal boxes so that we don't
get a lot of blown outside taps this
evening so it's all glamour here in the
english countryside this winter chris as
i'm sure it is so you ask everyone on
your podcast the same question to start
your show
so i'm going to reverse it round what
does high performance mean to you
um interestingly right high performance
means something totally different to me
now that i've spent two years
interviewing people for the high
performance podcast because
i sort of
like i really wanted when i started high
performance for people to
get sort of punched between the eyes
with a real
dawning realization of how hard you have
to work and how much you have to
struggle and how sacrifice is key
and how graft is everything to be
successful and that's really what i
thought and what i believed and it's
only through the conversations we've had
on high performance that i've i've
realized that all of those things are
true you do have to work hard there is
sacrifice consistency is absolutely
vital you have to make sure that passion
is central to everything that you do
but none of it is worth doing if it
doesn't take you to a place of being
happier or being more content or feeling
um
like you're in a better headspace and i
didn't i never considered that until i
began high performance i just thought it
was sacrifice and struggle and graft and
now i realize it's sacrifice struggle
and graft as long as it makes you happy
and that's actually been
kind of like a good thing for me to
understand really because i think it's
important that
people don't listen to high performance
and come to our podcast
um and because it is the whole point of
this podcast is that we get straight in
with the questions that matter
immediately there's no floating around
the surface there's no messing around
it's like right tell us the secrets tell
us what you've learned let your lived
experience be a lesson for somebody else
and so i'm always wary that
that can be quite hard and tough because
some people who are high performers do
live hard and tough lives that's how
they've got to where they've got to so
i'd now always caveat it with this is
absolutely fine but it isn't for
everyone and you only need to live this
kind of life if it makes you happy um
and i think also an understanding chris
that
like high performance doesn't mean being
an olympian doesn't mean being a
billionaire doesn't mean being a tech
entrepreneur doesn't mean being the best
investor in the country
it sort of means
finding what your own high performance
is and for some people that is literally
being happier than they were yesterday
or having a better relationship with
their kids or being able to have that
conversation with their boss that
they've been putting off for the last 12
months if listening to the high
performance podcast gets them to that
level of high performance their own
version of high performance then i'm
happy
that sounds a lot more like holistic
performance than high performance it
sounds like a much more well-rounded way
of viewing what high performance is i
think it probably is but then i think
that the more conversations we've had
with people the more that you don't have
to have either high performance or
holistic performance
you can have holistic high performance
and actually that is the healthiest high
performance to have like
it shouldn't just be graft and effort
you know for for people listening to
this if they're in the states they might
not know of johnny wilkinson the england
rugby player won the world cup with
england you know listeners in australia
and south africa and the uk will know
that name really well but he said to us
when he came on high performance that he
felt that the book that he wrote after
winning the world cup would have created
a mental health spike in young men
because it was all about
sacrifice everything back against the
wall graft grit determination struggle
failure that's what you need in your
life and now he realizes that all that
does is lead to more of the same and
actually now he's a guy who tries to
live in flow he's become really
spiritual the way he talks it's almost
buddhist like the conversations we have
he's he's he's must have studied
buddhism
i think from the conversations we have
he wouldn't be going to the places that
he he does unless he had um it was such
an enlightening conversation and that's
just a reminder isn't it that
what is it the stoic saying no man steps
in the same river twice because the
river's changed and so is the man
it's a reminder that even someone who's
got to the top of their chosen game in
his case it was rugby by having a
certain approach can totally totally
change that approach
for the rest of their life when they're
enlightened and i think i have been
enlightened by high performance i'm a
totally different person to the person
that started that podcast couple years
ago
just how surprised were you when you sat
down with johnny wilkinson because i've
shared that podcast to an awful lot of
people saying this sounds like a man
that is very aligned very awakened he
sounds like someone who's been on 100
ayahuasca retreats not somebody that
once won the rugby world cup yeah yeah
and think of the bravery it takes to
come and talk like that by the way
you know because a lot of not just the
rugby world but a lot of the sporting
world and a lot of the world still
thinks in the way he used to think
and i think that for him to come on and
talk as he did is testament not just to
him as a person
um
but i i'd like to think testament to the
fact that as a as a society i think
we're changing and we're listening more
than ever we've still got a lot further
to go but how much of a surprise was it
chris mate that was a surprise like you
know how it is you do an interview with
someone you have your questions right
i didn't ask a single question on my
piece of paper or on my laptop for the
whole hour and a half that we sat with
him and
i mean you've obviously listened to it a
few times i don't think we talked about
rugby really at all and to have someone
tell you that winning the rugby world
cup is no more important than doing the
washing up
and for me not to be able to understand
that even one percent and for him to
then explain well if rugby is more
important and i'm no longer a rope
player am i less important and that both
of them is just using your body to
achieve a goal
there lies enlightenment for me absolute
education for me total change of mindset
for me
and
like you feel
you feel really honored right when
someone sits and talks to you and they
say
the biggest thing that i've learned is
to be in the present to be fully engaged
in the moment and i right now i'm fully
engaged talking to you
i'm not thinking about what happened
yesterday because it's gone i'm not
thinking about what happens later
because that's just a story right now
we're in this room together we're having
a conversation and i'm totally all in
i'm fully engaged that is like
you realize when you have that
conversation with someone how
how rare it is to have that feeling with
someone we don't live in a world like
that anymore we live in a world where
you're talking to people while they're
scrolling their instagram or you're
chatting to them while they're flicking
through netflix or they're wondering
what's for dinner or they're asking
questions about tomorrow like how often
in all seriousness chris do you feel
really totally engaged with somebody
when i do this
when i do this is is the most the most
float state that i find
and i'd say to everybody that listens to
the show if you don't have an outlet
where you can have a conversation with
someone undistracted for 30 minutes a
week you need to try and find time for
that you know record it we've forgotten
it mate we've people don't even
understand what you're talking about
anymore when you talk about you in a
flow state having a conversation we
don't even know what that skill is
anymore the art form is gone
like i have people saying to me
podcast i look at your price now along
not sure and i'm like well you can't
spare one hour one hour to listen to
someone who is a world-class operator in
their chosen field and by the way
they are happy to sit and tell me
everything they've learned and they're
going to give it to you for free so you
can improve your mindset and change your
life you can't be [ __ ] to give an hour
to that
that's the world we're in now 15 second
video no problem at all edited version
of my life put on instagram to make
myself look good and make other people
feel bad no worries i can do that i can
sit and do an hour of netflix every
night but i haven't got time for it i
ain't got time for the podcast it's it's
math it's what the world is changing
before our eyes and
we're kind of like i actually love how
successful and how popular podcasts are
because it's almost to me now it's the
final great bastion of actual
conversation
like i don't have this sort of
conversation with anyone in my life and
then i come on here and i talk to you
you're in texas i'm in norwich we've
never even met before and we're having
like a deeper better conversation than
you ever have with anyone when you're in
in the same room with them because we
lost the art
i would say that there's a counter
culture coming in my experience and this
might be my selection bias for the
people that i'm around
i
i'm around people who hunger for a
slower lifestyle they genuinely want to
chop wood carry water they want to have
indulging conversations where they allow
themselves to fully marinate in whatever
it is that they're talking about and i
think that over time as with everything
right something swings to an extreme of
one way and then it swings back and i do
think that the the slower media
revolution that we're seeing with longer
form conversations i think that that's
going to be there one of the things you
you mentioned there um that was really
interesting to do with johnny wilkinson
is the
battle between high performance and
happiness i think and there's a there
feels like there's a tension that's
going on there
do you think that high performers are
more or less happy than most people on
average
uh less happy i think
yeah yeah i think that um
and i think that's something that we
need to be really overt about i'm really
honest about on the podcast let's not
sit here and try and pretend that being
a high performer is easy because it
isn't
but the great thing about the people
that join us
is that they've been on the journey
they've had the goal-oriented approach
to life they've realized when they've
got to that goal that actually it
doesn't feel as good
as they hoped it would and they didn't
enjoy the journey because all they were
focusing on was the goal and now they're
happy to come on high performance and
tell us that winning champions leagues
winning world cups
managing national teams managing premier
league football teams becoming
billionaires becoming some of the best
known entertainers on the planet does
not top their cup up it does not fulfill
them what fulfills them is the journey
to get to those places and so i think
there is an absolute tension and you're
right it's a constant tug of war between
high performance and happiness
but what the people on high performance
have learned is how to be
high performing happy people
plenty of the time
and the answer
has become that they've tried the goal
orientated approach they've realized it
doesn't work for them and they've taken
on
being obsessed with the process and i
think that if there's one huge learning
from high performance it is that if you
can live a process driven life then
you'll get to a better place like
i have this wooden block always in my
study
uh it says on it
when my camera focuses you'll see it
come on camera
[Music]
well there you go there you go
it found it for a second
infinite purpose it says
right what's that mean to you
um it basically means that i never focus
on an outcome
um and i did for a long time so
previously there is previously i would
have said uh my new year's resolution is
to get a six-pack now my new year's
resolution is to just be fitter i would
have said um my new year's resolution is
to turn over
three million pounds this year now my
new year's resolution is to make my
business the healthiest and happiest
that i can make it
the great thing about infinite purpose
is that it's infinite so the infinite
purpose for the high performance podcast
is to have engaging and interesting
conversations with high achievers that
allows our listeners right across the
world to reach
a high performance life
more often
now the great thing about that is that
there is no end to that it's not oh
great i've reached high performance i'm
done it's it's never ending and i think
infinite purpose is a really powerful
tool that people should employ um and
i've employed it since
since we spoke to susie ma and susie ma
she was the
first ever runner-up who adam sugar
still invested in from the apprentice
here in the uk and she's created tropic
skin care and she does the whole thing
with an infinite purpose and i think the
other great thing about an infinite
purpose is if you have that at the
center of what you're doing it keeps
passion
and it keeps purpose at the heart of why
you're doing things because you know
there will be a purpose and a passion
for you having these conversations this
isn't just you filling your time there
are plenty of other things you could be
doing to fill your time right
but making sure that you live this
purpose-driven life
is so hugely rewarding it suddenly it
suddenly makes sense you know for me
i've done
20 years as a broadcaster children's bbc
formula one
premier league football champions league
football
i have never felt as useful
as i do now i never fear i've never felt
like i've had an impact on people's
lives as much as now and i feel like my
purpose is to shout as
loud and as proud as i can about the
power of the high performance podcast
and the book that we've got coming out
in december
because it impacts people's lives for
good
and how can that ever be a bad thing you
know i want my kids to listen to these
episodes when i'm
long gone i want my grandkids to read
the book and get a real understanding of
what i was and what i represented and
i kind of feel lucky because one thing
that i'm not i'm not actually especially
eloquent right i'm actually relatively
simple in the way my brain processes
things
but the people that we have on the
podcast are so not simple and their
brains work at such an incredible level
like will ahmed the creator and founder
of whoop
um
there you go he's wearing his woot band
he comes on and talks to us and
there was one one question we asked him
and he said well i have never really
thought about that so let me try and
formulate an answer while i'm thinking
then he just goes and gives some
unbelievably bright and well thought out
well-constructed
smart
wonderful answer that i couldn't even
get close to
so
i know my limitations which is a
good one on the step to high performance
and i think i i can ask decent questions
and that's what i love doing and
i just feel for the first time useful
it's a lovely lovely feeling
let's sink one layer deeper into this
tension between happiness and high
performance yeah
what you brought up there is that um
people who have achieved championship or
accolade or success within a variety of
domains come to you and then they say
do you know what it is jake we i thought
that the top of the mountain was where i
wanted to be and i wasn't yeah is there
not a little bit of a situation here
where it's like a rich person telling a
poor person not to worry about money
because it's not going to make you happy
there's a quote from naval ravikant that
says it is far easier to achieve your
material desires than to renounce them
and what he's saying there is that open
loops of unfulfilled
degrees of success can torment us so
much that it's simply easier to do what
we need to do i'm wondering whether
there's a level of survivorship bias
amongst the high performers that have
made it to where they are and then they
can post rationalize about the journey
that got them there in any case
i think
that they're still on the journey i
think that's the key thing i actually
see it differently i see that
that they
thought that getting to the top of the
mountain was where they needed to be and
actually they're educated enough to
realize it's different like i can
remember and this is kind of weird right
because it's just a weird thing to do i
remember having an old mobile phone
right at the beginning of the mobile
phone era and i remember going to night
clubs in norwich and i just started out
on the television and i was working for
like a local tv channel
and i was so
utterly desperate right to walk into a
nightclub
and for people to recognize me and go oh
my god that's the guy from the tv
amazing and i had this such an inbuilt
desire to be successful and i used to
stand there at the bar and all my mates
are having a great time and having a
laugh and having drinks and i'm just a
ball of frustration because this desire
just to make it onto the tv
hadn't happened and i remember going to
the toilet in one of the nightclubs and
i just went into the tour in the cubicle
locked the door got my mobile phone and
i just banged on the numbers like that
really random whacking all these numbers
and i looked at it and i thought every
time i look at those numbers it's going
to remind me of how [ __ ] i feel right
now because i haven't made it to where i
want to get to and only when i get on
the television can i stop looking at
these numbers and realize that i've got
where i want to be of course i then end
up on the television
only a year later the show that i was
working on got commissioned for itv well
when i banged all those numbers into
that nightclub in norwich in the fit of
frustration like you'd think great
you've done it now you don't have to be
frustrated you no longer have to bang
the mobile phone you no longer have to
work and put the effort in the graft
but no because the way that our mind
works is that we immediately go on to
the next thing so it is absolutely
foolish to have an ambition to get to a
certain place and to conquer a mountain
it's like
you think of someone you buy like a car
or a watch or a pair of awesome trainers
or a lovely new bit of tech
for the first few days you're looking at
that thing and i bloody love that mobile
phone or those trainers are the ones
i've wanted for years or i've dreamt of
buying that car for so long and now i've
got it promise you man six months later
you don't think about those trainers you
don't care about the car you've bought
because you've had it for the last six
months you might get a nice feeling
sometimes when you get in it but you're
thinking
they've brought out a new model
i think i like the new model what i
could have got the more powerful engine
why didn't i get the sport model i've
just seen another version of this car
and they've got the 20-inch alloy wheels
[ __ ] why don't i get those
that's the way our brains work so it's
foolish to sit here and say to people
focus on the outcome oh by the way um
i have focused on the outcome and i can
tell you it's no good there's no point
then sitting here and telling people to
do what they've done and realize that
there's no joy at the end of it that's
not to say that like winning all these
things and doing all those brilliant
things of course it gives them a thrill
of course it's wonderful and of course
they're constantly trying to recreate
the high that they got from that
but i would never
want my kids
to live a life of
going for the goal
it has to be it has to be about the
process i can't
explain to them clearly enough
that
even if they really even if you love the
goal even if you get to the goal then it
is everything you've ever dreamed of
even if you do stand on the top of the
mountain and go oh my god i've done it
amazing
why can't you still love the process why
can't you still be totally totally
immersed and engaged with the process
because that's your parachute because
you might get to the mountain and it
might be [ __ ] so then it's a good job
you had the parachute packed and you
enjoyed the process if you get to the
mountain then it's amazing and it feels
better than you ever could have imagined
that's a bonus that's just another
additional layer of joy so i do see it
differently i i do i don't believe that
a goal orientated mindset is ever the
answer i think that focus on the process
and you will get to your goals anyway
you'll get there because focusing on the
process is the very thing that is going
to take you there focus on the outcome
is the very thing that takes you away
from the process and that's the very
worst thing you can do because the
process is the answer
i agree i think one of the reasons that
many high performers are addicted
to
the outcome is that feelings of
insufficiency are very motivating
if you believe that i will be whole when
i complete i achieve i am then it
motivates you to do more eddie hall is
the best example of this where he said
that he would have been uh single with
no relationship to his child and
probably dead if he hadn't won the
world's strongest man the year that he
had done because his marriage was on the
rocks because of how much he was
training he had no relationship with his
kid and he was on the verge of being
incredibly unhealthy at six foot three
two hundred and something kilos now
from the outside looking in we see this
glory and we see eddie hall world's
strongest man amazing accolade put it on
a pedestal
what you don't see is the price that
eddie o'haul had to pay for that and
that was a feeling of insufficiency and
i think that what you're trying to do
what it seems like you're trying to do
is shortcut people's belief that this
feeling of insufficiency is the only way
to get motivation that motivation can
come from a place of enoughness it can
come from a place of desire of growth of
wanting to be as good as you can but not
because that's going to fill a hole in
yourself this void that isn't being
enough the hole will still be there and
it will still be just as big if the hole
is there um we had hector bayern the
arsenal player come on our podcast did
you see the episode did you listen to it
no not that one she's brilliant he came
on and he said um
he said life life is like a candle he
said you um you have to live like a
candle
said me as a footballer when i'm in the
first team and i'm playing well then i'm
scoring goals and i'm getting one of the
match awards and all my mates are
ringing me up and we're going clubbing
you can allow the flame to grow and grow
and grow because everything's great and
then you get dropped and then the
manager doesn't talk to you and then
your teammates shun you a bit because
they're focusing on the players that are
in the team and the nightclubs you've
been going to don't call anymore to ask
you to come and have a table and your
mates that loved hanging out with you
because you're playing first in football
every week don't ring anymore and the
candle gets dim and dim and dim you're
saying you have to live a candle you
have to make the decision that your
flame is your flame and you're totally
steady with your flame so it doesn't
matter what happens around you because
the only thing that can make the
decision for the size of your flame is
your opinion of yourself and if you have
a low opinion of yourself i promise you
when you get to the goal at the end you
will still have the low opinion of
yourself
and if you don't get to the goal at the
end you'll have an even lower opinion of
yourself which makes being goal oriented
even more dangerous and even more risky
and i look at people all the time and i
think all of you are living in this
place where it is
but when but when but when but when but
when it's a nonsense man this is it
these are the good old days
you know we now look at photos of our
kids from two years ago they were so
small then two years ago we were looking
at photos of them two years before going
oh they're so small look how beautiful
they are you don't see it when you're in
it you can't wait until you've got no
stress or worry in your life before you
decide to be happy because guess what
you will always have stress and worry
and anxiety and problems and issues to
deal with so you have to decide now that
happiness is something that you're going
to have you can't wait until you've been
hugely successful before you start
focusing on charity and giving and
caring for other people
because that moment might never arrive
and actually the giving and the caring
and the loving and the empathy is going
to get you closer to a feeling of
happiness anyway and the happier you are
the more successful your life is like
there's no question about that happiness
is a form of success
and i see all around me people who are
telling me they're going to do this when
this happens and they were telling me
the same thing five years ago and five
years before that and they are still
going to the same parties and the same
pubs in the same job with the same
friends eating the same food
but they're still wishing they had a
different house and a different body and
a different circle of mates and a
different social life
but they're waiting for something and i
don't know what they're waiting for but
we have to evolve you have to explore
all the time
exploration is the key for all of these
high performance conversations that we
have you really have to break your life
down into all the little components and
say what is exactly the same here as it
was two or three years ago and is that a
good thing for me like you you're in
austin texas right because you're
exploring it's a place you've gone to
literally to explore to explore yourself
to explore your career to explore your
mindset explore your body
exploration is the answer
i'm interested in how people don't
identify with their mistakes how they
can do something have a setback you
talked about the the flame starting to
flicker away you get dropped you you try
something you know maybe somebody
wants to make these changes they want to
try and get lean next year they want to
take care of their health or their
family or whatever it is but they
encounter some problems or at the
absolute peak of the sport somebody
fails on the biggest stage
what have you found from speaking to
these guys about dealing with mistakes
and not identifying with them and not
having them as huge setbacks
it comes down to
taking responsibility chris basically i
mean a lot of the high performers that
join us take on what they call 100
responsibility and it's a powerful one
and it's a tool worth investigating and
basically you can do it over a day a
couple of days maybe a week and you take
100
responsibility and you take
responsibility for your colleagues that
aren't good enough at work will you take
responsibility for why that person isn't
putting their weight you might have a
difficult relationship with your partner
or your children instead of looking at
it and saying i wish they would talk
themselves out you take responsibility
for why that relationship isn't where
you would like it to be
and taking responsibility
gives you power
giving away responsibility gives away
control and if you give away control
you're giving away the opportunity to
solve the problems that are lying in
front of you
so
high achievers
take 100 responsibility but they take
100 responsibility especially for the
setbacks and i think what i want people
to understand because i always know when
someone doesn't really listen to high
performance because they say oh yeah
it's just people talking about why
they're successful and how great they
are and how the lessons they've learned
along the way i i'm not interested in
that because that's not actually how
life works and i always say to them
listen
successful people
fail way more often
than anybody else successful people fail
all the time i mean i can see when you
lift your arms up chris right your guns
are pretty big why are your guns big i
tell you why your guns are big because
for years and years and years you've
lifted until failure right
lift your failure lift until you can't
lift anymore because guess what happens
next time you go in the gym you lift
heavier and you lift longer because the
failure is where the growth is you need
to allow that failure into your life you
need to fail often
you need to be in that window where
failure is almost inevitable but
crucially you have to fail forwards you
have to seek the failure you have to
want the failure you have to completely
change your brain to understand that
when you talk about a footballer in
training
taking hundreds of free kicks
it's not training it's failing he's
failing free kick after free kick after
free kick so when the game starts he
scores that free kick and that's exactly
the way that life works
excuse me
you have to fail
to have the successes and
successful people turn failure into a
positive life if i look back at my own
life
i was bullied at school
at one of my high schools i had to move
schools in the end like that's a
difficult thing to go through at the
time
and then i got a job at mcdonald's and i
was told i had no communication skills
so i was fired fired from mcdonald's by
the way
that's a hard thing to take
and then um about six months after that
while i was doing my a-levels my grandma
sadly committed suicide that's a very
difficult thing to accept mentally when
you're a young guy because like
grandparents don't do that you know what
i mean they're the ones that are always
happy they're the ones that have made it
in life they're they're at the other end
they're just chilling so that was hard
then i failed my a levels
that was really difficult
and then i went to london and i went
through quite a tricky
mental health period just for about six
months where life just felt overwhelming
and i went and saw someone and they just
said to me
you just have to accept that you're
gonna have periods in your life where
you have kind of
difficult intrusive thoughts it's really
common for young men that's why
suicide rates are so high for young men
because they don't come and talk about
it they just think there's something
wrong with them and they go and do the
unthinkable
so all those moments in my life are
reminders to me
that what is hard for me
isn't necessarily bad for me and what i
might have seen at the time as a full
stop was just a comma
and i want people to understand that
you know there would constantly be
struggle and failure and set back and
knock back and potholes that you'd
stumble and trip into
but it is absolutely how you react to
those they're only negatives
if you choose for them to be a negative
and it's a really hard thing to hear but
i honestly believe that happiness is a
choice
do you love what happens
do you still have a chip on your
shoulder about some of those things from
your childhood
no
no i i like
i might have done at the time
but
what's the what is the benefit to that i
mean that having a chip on your shoulder
i think is like
well how does the old phrase go drinking
poison
and waiting for the other person to die
that's what it's you know having any
carrying any sort of negativity for
those things that happened i mean so i i
understand that's a perfectly rational
very very admirable way to have it in
your mind but that's not the situation
that most people get themselves to
certainly not naturally
yeah
so why don't i feel like that um yes
i think
i think that i've just reached i mean
i'm 43 right i've reached a point in my
life where
i'm more stable than ever before i'm
happier than ever before
i think i almost feel like
someone's opened the door and said have
a look through there
that's enlightenment right there that's
the truth that's what everyone would
love to see you've seen it now now shut
the door and go and tell people about it
that's honestly what i feel and it might
sound ridiculous and a bit trite but
when you when you do see that
enlightenment and all of those answers
that
happiness is a choice and bad things
will happen but you need to understand
the difference between fault and
responsibility loads of things will
happen to you that are not your fault
but they're still your responsibility
and when you realize that
you realize that
you're only going to get one shot at
this there's no point spending any time
worrying about
the people that bullied me over 20 years
ago because they don't care whether i'm
worried about them there's no point
carrying any
frustration with my grandma that she
didn't talk to us
and
and share her fears because
um
she isn't here anymore and all we should
really be doing is thinking of the good
times we had together there's no point
worrying about the person that fired me
from mcdonald's for a lack of
communication skills because i didn't
want to work at mcdonald's anyway for my
whole life there's no frustration i
failed my a levels because going back to
school to redo my a-levels
was the thing that got me into
television because the very day that i
returned to school my politics teacher
had a letter in his hand from a local tv
channel well if that isn't a message
from somewhere
telling you to realize that the bad
stuff is also the good stuff i don't
know what is and i certainly don't have
any issues anymore about the fact that i
went through some struggles with my
mental health because i look at that as
something that i was allowed to
experience so that if my little boy
sebastian ever has a similar thing i can
say listen son can i just and i will
when he's 15 16 i am going to sit him
down and say listen i'm going to tell
you exactly what went through your dad's
mind when i was 21 and how scary it was
and that actually it was my brain
playing a trick
because your brain is going to play
tricks all your life
looking into the future seb is just
writing stories
and i was writing negative stories and
then choosing to believe them and guess
what millions of people do that every
minute of every day
you've got the choice mate to write
really good stories and then chase them
down and that would be my advice to him
i really wish that we could gift other
people and ourselves
the perspective that broad perspective
that you have you know when you look
back on a memory and you see it in the
wider context of things
you see it with this real
equanimity you understand why it was
there you understand why it occurred you
see how you dealt with it
but you're not you're not viscerally
caught up you're not swept away in the
phenomenological experience of it a man
like i really really wish if you could
gift people that you know you have a
friend that's going through something
and they're really really suffering and
you want to you want to tell them look
dude just just hold on get through it
day by day you're going to be fine
your ability to look back on all of
these situations in the broader context
as a part of the narrative to create
this person that you've become today
i just that would be
if you were able to do that and you were
able to give someone that perspective
while they were suffering while they
were going through some challenges
that would be one hell of a
one hell of a miracle yeah you're
totally right but part of getting to
hear is going through that isn't it
and that's the difficult thing and
that's where it's a real challenge
because i look at my kids and i wouldn't
wish any of those things on them
but
i do want them to struggle i absolutely
do want my kids to struggle i want my
kids to fail i spend my life seeing
these helicopter parents yeah
hovering around their kids all the time
don't walk in there don't touch that
don't trip there i mean the phrase be
careful oh i hate it be careful okay
where are you going all right well be
careful why be careful why be careful
okay be joyful okay be full of fun be
carefree be happy that's what we should
be saying to our kids be careful ugh
horrible because what happens is we
smooth the path in front of our children
oh there's a problem with the teacher
i'll go speak to the teacher i'm not
getting on with this kid in class i'll
speak to their parents oh i've got this
happening at school sit down let me give
you all the answers and help you smooth
the path smooth the path smooth the path
no resilience gets built they get to 21
they get told at their first job
interview they haven't got the job crash
and burn
crash and burn because they haven't got
the resilience if you were to ask me the
single biggest
trait that high performers have from the
conversations on our podcast chris
resilience
absolutely without question they have
resilience
and we have to find a way of instilling
resilience in people what does
resilience mean to you
the ability to just push on through the
ability to realize
that what is now is not forever that all
things pass and all things change
nothing is permanent
and
everything is a lesson everything is
part of learning and the biggest
resilience lesson for me is that i'm in
control of it you are absolutely inc and
people hate that when you talk about
happiness being a choice people really
struggle with it
because all this [ __ ] things happen to
me why how can happiness be a choice i
can't choose to be happy in the midst of
all this well you can
you can choose to be happy the way that
you react to something is entirely on
you you know you me and you right have a
row on on this conversation this evening
yeah that's the thing that's happened if
in two days time you and me are still
dwelling on it
or texting each other going yeah you've
really pissed me off that's not the
thing that happened that's our reaction
to the thing that happened and that's
the bit that we can control
and once you realize that you can
control your response and reaction to
everything that happens in your life
then you're totally bulletproof and when
you're totally bulletproof
you're in flow and you're living with a
real sense of freedom you've spoken to a
lot of athletes that have performed
under extreme pressure and obviously
there's a lot of emotions flowing
through their systems there what are
some of the lessons that you've got
about coping with pressure and managing
motions like that
well again it comes back to control it's
very interesting that
all of the athletes that we speak to i
mean there's a great phrase that trauma
leads to triumph and we have had
conversations
with high performer after high performer
where when we talk about their success
they almost instantaneously relate it
back to a struggle or a trial that they
went through and i don't think there's a
coincidence there because i think that
the challenges that they faced years
before although they may seem far
greater than standing on a diving board
or standing on a running track or lining
up to kick off a football match it's
those struggles and those challenges
that they faced far greater than this
one that have equipped them for dealing
with this much smaller challenge that
lies in front of them on that day
and it brings us back to the same
conversation that we hear lots of people
use pressure being a privilege these
people understand
that pressure is a privilege and they
are
wired in a way that they chase it and
they want it and they enjoy it and they
savour it
what's a lesson that's had the biggest
impact on your performance do you think
it's really
it's a really good question
because i take little snippets of
everyone that's joined us in high
performance but i think
i think the person that put it best to
us was matthew mcconaughey when he
joined us on the podcast and he spoke
about
his mum telling him just keep on going
just keep on going and he said to us but
mama if i keep running around a running
track and every time i run around a
running track i step in
dog mess on exactly the same corner
every single time and you say just go
again just go again just go again
i'm not learning the lessons so yeah
i'll just go again but i'll go again
with the slight learning that i've taken
from that but what i won't do is stop
running i'll keep on going and i think
that that's the biggest learning for me
from the conversations we've had on high
performance is that you're constantly
learning constantly adapting constantly
evolving you and i are different people
to the people that started this
conversation an hour ago right but we're
still heading in the same direction just
with a very slight tilt because i'm
learning from you you're learning from
me we're adapting we're evolving
and i guess
i
i used to be too fixed in my mindset
this was what i wanted to achieve this
was how i was going to achieve it and
these were all the bullet points to get
myself to that place
now i'm way more flexible in my thinking
and my approach and i think
in this world we need to be totally
flexible
who do you think surprised you the most
of all of the guys you've spoken to
no there's no question really i imagine
yeah i was like
this is not the conversation i was
expecting i mean people have come up
with amazing things but
johnny wilkinson is the one that
surprised me the most the greatest
bulletproof mindset of everyone that's
joined us was the explorer nims purger
and you know how i talk on here about
happiness being a choice and
fault versus responsibility and
realizing that what's not your fault is
still your responsibility
nims gave us the single most amazing
example of that when he was looking to
break the world record for climbing the
world's highest mountains and he comes
out of his tent in the morning and
someone stolen his oxygen
and he's like he said to us he said when
you're climbing mountains and you're in
the death zone and you're making an
attempt on the summit
taking someone's oxygen is a crime
it's it's like murder
yeah because taking that oxygen is
taking away the one thing that's
guaranteed to keep them alive
what do you do in that situation
you go back down the mountain because
you haven't got enough oxygen to get to
the top
or
you totally reframe your thinking and
you say right i'm going to sum it i'm
going to sum it quicker because i've
only got one bottle of oxygen rather
than two however i'm really pleased that
someone stole on my oxygen
that was his mindset why was he pleased
because he wrote a story in his head
that while he was asleep at night
someone on the mountain had a medical
emergency and the only way to save that
person's life was to get them some
additional oxygen and the oxygen was
found outside his tent and that oxygen
was taken to that person that person's
life was saved thanks to nim's oxygen so
not only has his oxygen saved someone
else's life
but he's also
going to take control and summit the
mountain with one bottle of oxygen and
he went to the top of the mountain and
he summited and he came back down now
that is the absolute
prime example to me of someone
taking responsibility taking control for
their own mindset of course someone
didn't take his oxygen because it was
saving someone's life the chances of
that is so slim but what's the point in
him thinking otherwise
why not take immediate control of the
situation
play it to your favor we should be doing
that all day every day every little
situation that
unfolds and arises in our lives
nims is built different he was on the
show uh talking about
his what was it becoming impossible what
was his book
um
and uh
man that guy is
what i think so beautiful about about
him and a lot of the other people that
you speak to on the show as well is this
blend of
savagery with presents
it's the fact that they're able to
switch on this absolute extreme level of
performance and aggression nims i i
didn't understand where the word
trailblazing came from that when you're
climbing up a mountain and you're going
through snow the person at the front
essentially acts as a plow and if your
waist deep or chest deep in snow the
person at the front isn't just walking
they're also sort of pushing out of the
way and the way that they walk is this
sort of they shuffle forward they lean
their body in then they shuffle they
lean their body in and nim said he
always wanted to be the trailblazer i
mean
part of me thinks that the guys
masochist that just loves suffering and
that may a little bit of that may be
true but the other part of it is that
he just wants to be the person that's
leading from the front and
that as you say you know for high
performance that's
gold
yep he was amazing he uh
i embarrassed myself at one point by
standing up with my arms in the air just
shouting you're so inspirational
like i just want to go for a beer with
him don't you
yeah he's a great guy um one of the
things that i find quite interesting
we're talking a lot about theory here
and we've got some of the lessons out of
that but moving from theory to action is
the most important part so give me some
of the daily practices that you've built
to instantiate these lessons
i always think when it comes to this
moment right we have to be really honest
okay because i hear lots of people
talking on podcasts and other places
where they set
unrealistic challenges for people like
you and i to live with so i would love
to say i wake up every morning at 20
minutes of meditation
lemon sliced into warm water make sure i
get eight hours of sleep every night uh
make a diary of my plan for the day have
a gratitude journal at the end of the
day that i write in
i don't do any of that chris right i
don't do any of that i get out of bed
knackered because i work too much and
the kids coming out of bed at night and
sebastian's like legs smashing to my
face he's six years old and
florence wakes up grumpy most of the
time and then we struggle to get out of
the house on time because
we're doing the school run and then i
feel like i have a production company in
london we've got 200 staff i feel a real
responsibility for looking out for them
and making sure that business is driving
forwards i've got my tv presenting work
i've got the podcast stuff i've got all
kinds of little bits rolling around
we've got some building work going on at
home at the moment i've got family and
friends that i feel don't see enough of
me and they let me know about that on a
pretty regular basis and i don't get
into the gym as often as i would like
and i snack too much in the evenings
which gives me belly fat which
frustrates me all of that right is the
truth okay
but among all of that
i'm absolutely
happy
and calm and centered and relaxed with
it all because high performance is not
about chasing perfection
and i really need to make that clear
because i think that we set unattainable
goals for people you know you watch a
james bond film you want to be james
bond hey guys he's a fictional bloody
character okay you cannot
kill 500 men armed with oozies with one
single handgun and a karate chop okay
that's not the way the world works
but from the high performance
conversations
the first thing that i am is constantly
optimistic
everything can be a good thing no matter
whether at the time it feels like a
difficult thing it can be a good thing
i'm an obsessive list writer i think
it's really important to write down all
the things that and i don't write lists
of jobs i've got to do i write down a
list of things that i'm finding
frustrating at the moment
um because one of the things that i
really like is not taking specific
action to solve those things but i
believe that by writing those things
down and just knowing what they are then
the universe is going to do its bit and
solve those and
i could look at everything on the list
of the last
five years
everything has solved itself
and i think it's because
almost subconsciously you do the things
that you need to do to solve those
problems and and to get there so i'm not
i'm an obsessive list writer i'm an
absolute firm believer in not letting
the shitty little things in life get you
down if something doesn't matter in five
years don't worry about it for five
seconds you stub your toe you get a
parking ticket
you lose your wallet you spill some food
down your front at dinner you're late
for a meeting there's no point worrying
about any of those things because i tell
you in five years nobody will even
remember they ever happened and you're
wasting your time and you're wasting
your energy
and then
living in them living in the now like
being totally connected to you here in
five minutes time i'll go and have
dinner with my kids and that is total
connection to them no mobile phones no
conversation or no thought process about
what's happening later or what happened
yesterday what comes next that is just
totally invested in them
my big non-negotiable isn't no matter
where i am in the uk no matter what i'm
working on i come home i make sure i
come home and i 100 do the school run so
you can hear my voice doesn't sound
great i've had three hours sleep the
last two nights because i was working on
the champions league and we live a
couple of hours out of london so by the
time i get home it's two o'clock in the
morning and um and the kids wake up
sometime before six a.m
um so that has its challenges but that's
the way i want to live because i want to
be present for my kids you know in years
to come i don't want someone to say man
i listened to your dad's podcast and i
read his books what was he like as a dad
and for them to say didn't really see
him
i want all the things that i talk about
and write about and believe in for them
to get the real genuine experience of
that not the words aren't good enough
they have to feel it from me every
single day
and
just learning learning all the time to
remember to be grateful for all the
things in my life and
sometimes i just get that moment where a
huge smile comes across my face and i
just think i just got it's ridiculous
it's absolutely ridiculous my life and
the things that are going on and the
things that i'm doing
and
actually
lots of people should feel the same but
lots of people don't feel the same they
don't practice gratitude and gratitude i
think is like a muscle i do think you
have to work at it i do think you have
to exercise it um and then it comes
naturally my tip for that for anyone
that um
struggles with that it really starts
with self-talk it starts with being
positive so every time a negative
thought comes into your head stop that
negative thought and just replace it
instantly with five good things
just five things that are great and they
don't have to be massive things so i
don't know if i
if i come out of here and i think to
myself vladimir i've been really busy i
haven't really spoken to harriet much
it's really important at that moment to
come up with five things that have been
really good today but we woke up
together this morning and i made her a
cup of tea and we did the school run
together and she had a headache earlier
when i got some tablets and made us some
water and it's still only seven o'clock
in the evening so we're still going to
get the whole evening together and the
great thing is i've recognized it so
tomorrow i can be extra present and
extra good those are the five things to
counter out that one negative thing that
kind of mindset is there for everybody
and um
that's a long-winded way of saying that
i've picked up a few tips from people in
high performance but i'm far from
perfect
i think that the
post
high performance high performance or the
holistic high performance that we've
come up with
i think that that really is going to be
over the next few years
where a huge movement for people goes
the
hustle and grind until your eyes bleed
world is long gone and
very quickly people realize that as you
said if it's not in the purpose of
making you happy
what are you doing like why why are you
pursuing this thing if you sacrifice so
much of yourself on the route to success
that it makes the success pointless the
destination is literally
worthless yeah and but by the way chris
i want to be a husk of a man by the time
i'm done like i want to ex i want to
just
push every single little sinew
to live the life that i want right but i
want to do it with happiness and with
gratitude and with a full heart and
because it makes me happy do you know
what i mean by that yeah well so one of
one of the problems that you have is
that people can sacrifice themselves
right they can burn themselves to a
crisp the candle can go at both ends but
they can do that in service of something
that they end up finding wasn't
worthwhile yeah yeah yeah so i think the
important thing i really want to make
make sure that people take away from
this is that what you've done
you are prepared to go all in on a
number of different pursuits
but you have made the decision you've
done the self-work you've decided these
are the non-negotiables that i want to
care about in my life it sounds like
family presenting podcasts and serving
the wider community uh the production
company leaving a legacy you know
something like that right
you're prepared to completely eviscerate
yourself
in service of that
but the reason that you can do that and
feel whole and feel like you're coming
at that from a holistic high performance
place
is that you know that those things are
what you what you genuinely want to
achieve
yeah
you've absolutely nailed it by the way
you've read you've read the room
completely right that's totally right i
want to be
i want to be drained and done by the end
right i want to leave nothing on the
table but you're totally right i want to
do it all
in pursuit of things that i genuinely
care about because i think that that's
where real freedom is real freedom isn't
being able to really do the things that
you want to do
but i do believe that when you found the
things that you really want to do you
need to
consistently
be all in as long as they make you happy
yeah
i love it jay humphries ladies and
gentlemen uh people want to check out
the book where should they go
uh go to thehighperformancepodcast.com
you can order the book there you can get
tickets to our uk tour in 2022 you can
join our members club the high
performance circle you can get loads
more access to brilliant guests and
speakers and
thinkers who've got far more eloquent
things to say than me um it's just my
honor really to curate it and try and
bring it all together to people i love
what you're doing jake i hope you keep
going
mate i really appreciate it thanks very
much for your time what's happening
people thank you very much for tuning in
if you enjoyed that episode then press
here for a selection of the best clips
from the podcast over the last few weeks
and don't forget to subscribe
peace
you